imagine making a career move and being
called a snake for it imagine leaving
behind a flagging roster just to see
them succeed with imagine going from
being the youngest major champion to
being ridden off at just 21 years old
every made the pretty bad decision even
a Stratus that's one of the worst moves
carbides decision to leave a straw list
for north is one of the most
controversial roster changes in the
history of csgo and between the memes
the disrespect and his quest for
redemption it affects him to this day
[Music]
kara I was once a young rising star in
the world of CS and yes apparently his
name is care by not care be everyone
been calling you heavy and Care Bear or
those of the mad stuff right just so set
the record straight
it's care by actually deciding anyway
care by was a major MVP the youngest
major champion ever and as far as many
people were concerned the best player on
a straw Louis but then in a shocking
twist you left and though ditching a
straw list might seem like an insane
move now it was particularly
controversial back when it happened in
2018 see the way carob I did it pissed
everyone off I feel still feel like
we're good friends but in all honesty I
we would just have appreciated a
conversation about it because also still
at the moment we really don't know why
he left before the split er I spent two
years with the Danish kings of csgo
except they were really kings back then
the astrologer carebye joined back in
2016 was having a hard time finding its
groove
they were plagued by inconsistency and
famous for choking Estrada's looking
some of the best form we've ever seen
the men coming into this fight the
semi-final and the look on device's face
he's had a shocker every game to finish
things off there at the major but hereby
was supposed to fix that when I first
took tour I thought I could feel really
good throughout 2016 so I knew that
if they were gonna call somebody most
like it could be me carob I was brought
into the team by their coach Sonic who
knew him from his time coaching Dignitas
and his effect on the team was immediate
[ __ ] to free I find two kills this
time I'll break this back to a
three-on-three Australis and they're
still carry with three head shots and
with care by on the lineup Astralis went
into the manger ready to shred their
competitors tell us about astrology own
can you've got them winning the whole
thing can't wait to hear this yeah I
mean here's the thing about Australia's
much like some of the older lineups
they've had they pretty much got it all
in terms of the pieces on paper he
wanted it even you got cavi who's kind
of a Youngblood and actually claims it
seems like he's kind of activated if
this TVs become a pretty legit player
who's having big-time performances
despite their middling performance in
the group stage a straw went into the
playoffs swinging they brought down Navi
15 seconds again the pub needs to go
down as it's running into the cross and
he's delivering every single thought
fnatic fnatic in the most magical way of
pulling it back but look at Jeremy right
time right place and then in the grand
finals furnace Pro the bomb has been
picked up by de Freitas they get the
spray Neil takes one it's out of that
Estrada's that way the fun
at just 18 years old carebye became the
youngest player to ever win a major and
thanks to his incredible performance he
was even named MVP it became the
highlight of his career the moment which
all of his future victories would be
measured against but the Cinderella
story couldn't last forever
while Australis remained a fixture in
the competitive scene after the major
their results weren't exactly top-tier
you can clearly see that astrologer
thrown in the towel at this stage QB
question of who is gonna take and it's
gonna be like crow so fnatic in style
will sweep aside astralis who will be
bitterly disappointed after very poor
performance here in Group A and they go
out at the 2018 Boston major Australis
didn't even make it out of the group
stage
Charlotte sent packing from cloud 9 who
continued into the tournament they got a
play later today unfortunately enters
forest Rallis for your danes they're
eliminated that ends the playoff streak
of a couple big players and it ends no
Danish teams into the playoffs at Boston
in just five days after that disastrous
major run it was time to renew contracts
but carabine was nowhere to be found at
any typed in a group chat on facebook
made a new one said mary says nails at
me for like three days do you know
anything have you told with him we're
like no when he was supposed to go on a
skiing vacation and everything and then
like it started continuing a little bit
I can't remember how many days it were
but suddenly it was like it was so
obvious some of I can remember it was
called his dad and he said he was sick
with the flu and we like can you please
tell us if he's gonna sign or not
because we need to find a new player and
just like it was crazy and I was like
when I got the news when I'm saying I
was still on vacation I was obviously
shocked I didn't know what to say right
glaive was left speechless carob I call
it the hardest decision of his career it
all happened so quickly so strangely the
fans couldn't even believe it but
finally an announcement from North
confirmed everything carob I had moved
on leaving his stunned straw was
teammates behind sonic who was the
mastermind behind care by joining a
straws in the first place felt the full
sting of this decision in his book he
later wrote that care believing was
human
for a straw Louis and for him personally
but Kara mine was more focused on
helping North succeed than worrying what
people thought of him for leaving a
straw Louis my biggest dreams was to to
go and win again and even though your
dreams might not always come when you
expect it she's still just enjoy it and
learn from your defeats as well and
that's what I'm gonna keep trying to do
joining a new team was supposed to help
carabine shine as a great player not
just one part of a great roster
this isn't worse it was a really good
opportunity for me I felt like I was the
last piece of the puzzle so I was just
really timid to go here when you have a
team that wants you so bad and see you
for the quality of that qualities and
talent you have so it was a hard
decision but I think definitely it was
the right decision career-wise for me
back in astrologists was brought in to
replace care by and together they took
the number one spot on the hltv rankings
in april 2018 holding on for it for a
year straight even winning three
back-to-back majors in the process I'm
really happy that we have Maggie's
component when you look at the results
we have now and that we didn't have back
then I guess you could say that Maggie's
is one of the best roster moves this
year it wasn't like a master move that
we wanted to do in the beginning but now
when we are here I'm really happy that
it came out this way and yeah I'm kind
of hanging carebye but for doing what he
did but Shirley care by the rising young
star was right behind a straw list with
North right well not exactly
North was not living up to the hype and
the team was failing to deliver the
disappointment was palpable it's curvy
now 1v3 can't kirby save it but more
police say their hopes dreams and
desires in this London major it creeps
closer he's got 40 seconds three players
crush is weak he will be annihilated as
well all streams in this major Vega
squadron who would have thought it they
qualify over north into the new legend
space I cannot believe what I just saw
but Kara my's time on North hasn't been
without its bright spots and the
brightest of all was their victory at
Dreamhack Master Stockholm 2018 because
they didn't just win the tournament they
beat a straw
remember North Cobb eatin 16-0 about two
hours ago on this very back back to do
it again Haney sleep they happen in
century but that is in in ms Dell
continues to land he's not missing any
time soon ready to go he delivers just a
look at their other their depth three
kills come his way now the Eco first was
a quick one supposed to be site and
benefits melted funny
the leak of a double days till Disney
those early days and device will be the
last player made us justify this time
and wait
most fans saw Stockholm as vindication
for care by a chance to redeem his
decision to leave Astralis kirby
obviously he turned that back on
Australia at the start of the year it's
been a long grind for him it's been hard
work and finally he's toppled them he's
won a big trophy he's done it he's done
what he set out to do and none of us
believed there was some tough times for
North's and tough times for curia but to
be able to do what he set out to
accomplish is huge whatever difficulties
carebye faces with his current team his
passion for the game makes it all worth
it you need to have true love for
Counter Strike in order for it being
worth it and you really need the passion
and you need to have it as like almost
your biggest goal as being one of the
best care by doesn't want to be defined
by that legacy of the promising rising
star he was all those years ago he's out
here to prove that while the past is
important it doesn't have to define his
future
[Music]